i know who you are
you know who you are
just say it
come on
hey guys pete here over the last couple
of days there's been a lot of discussion
about the back-to-back trailers better
call saul just put out for the final
episodes we're just a little more than
one week away from the premiere of
episode 8 and there's some potential
good news and some potential bad news in
this pair of teasers the good news is
that we got what appears to be our first
look at actual new footage from the
final episodes and the bad news is that
it looks like they had to recast the
character jeff who was originally played
by the actor don harvey that's what i'm
here to talk about and if any of that
sounds like spoilers or you're averse to
speculation then this video won't be for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it we got a couple of teasers
over the last two days and the first one
which is called gene's world created
quite the stir in that we see mostly
recycled footage of gene takavic in
omaha there are shots of him working at
cinnabon and making himself a rusty nail
cocktail at home from the very first
episode from season 5 there's a shot of
him looking paranoid peeking out his
window one of him pouring out the
diamonds he has hidden in a band-aid tin
on his table and him on the phone
telling ed to disappear that he got made
before he says i'm going to fix it
myself which is of course how they ended
the last scene that we've seen of him
from season 4 there's a shot of him in
the backseat of jeff's cab followed by
one of him looking scared after he gets
out all of this old footage is there to
remind us of gene's situation his frame
of mind and what he was up to when we
last saw him there's not much that
stands out in that except maybe showing
the diamonds ties in with the idea of
him paying jeff off which the last
teaser seemed to hint at they did choose
to show two shots of him peeking out of
the window from different seasons but
one's interior and one's exterior so
they naturally go together and to me
that just reinforces that he's
constantly looking over his shoulder the
new footage is an overhead shot of
someone eating a cinnabon with a knife
and fork and it's a mystery as to who
this is because they're wearing a
wedding ring we know jimmy never wore
one and in the scenes where don harvey
played jeff he isn't wearing one either
the big thing in this trailer that got
everyone talking was that even though
it's cut together with saul sitting in
the back seat the shots of jeff's cab
now have a different actor sitting in
the driver's seat in a much brighter
looking scene the voice also sounds a
little bit off when he says it's you it
is you right away people started
guessing that they recast the actor my
initial thought was that gene had called
up the taxi company like jeff told him
to in the mall scene and someone else
had to come pick him up in his car i
knew dawn harvey was in we own the city
which just wrapped up on hbo and figured
that they probably were filmed at the
same time i built an elaborate theory
that included schedule changes because
of bob's heart attack and coveted
restrictions that would make gene
meeting someone else in jeff's circle
necessary but i did assume that the
original actor would still be involved
in some way primarily because i think
that gene going after jeff is going to
be a big part of how the series comes to
an end and these two new teasers do kind
of reinforce that idea
not long after i put my super theory
together it took a couple of quick hits
first the fan account all about saul
posted that they had inside information
that jeff had been recast then the
second teaser came out where the new
actor is wearing the same sweater that
jeff had on in the season 5 mall scene i
was able to imagine someone else driving
his car but them doing that while
wearing his sweater doesn't work nearly
as well i will come back to the details
about the recast but first i want to
talk about the second teaser that opens
with the albuquerque isotopes air
freshener dangling from the rear view
mirror of jeff's cab the camera switches
from that to focus on the driver looking
back just like it did when the character
was first introduced when he picked up
gene at the hospital after he collapsed
in the kitchen at cinnabon in this
version you see that this is a
completely unrelated shot of him driving
during the day they name this one you
know who you are and you hear some of
the dialogue from when they first talked
remember he was pressuring him into
admitting that he was saul goodman from
the commercials he used to always see
when he lived in albuquerque here you
can tell without question that this is
not don harvey's voice as i mentioned
this is during the day so this is brand
new footage with a brand new actor with
some dialogue that's been re-recorded in
his voice that all seems to be in line
with recasting the character i suppose
that hearing these lines in his voice
led some people to think that they
re-shot the scenes with jeff completely
but i don't think that really makes
sense also in all about saul's post they
said that the reshoot in the cab was an
introduction to the new jeff so that we
can be prepared to see that when it airs
and hopefully not be so jarring
initially that sounded like they redid
those scenes but after seeing the second
bit of footage that happens at a
different time and place it seems more
likely that they just added the new
actor's voice to signal the change the
reason for the recast seems to be
schedule conflicts based on don harvey's
role in we own the city while jeff is an
important character for better call saul
he's not part of the main cast i'm not
entirely sure how those things work but
it doesn't seem like they would be able
to keep him on contract between seasons
it is disappointing because he did such
a good job in the short amount of time
he had on screen but these things happen
pretty often if you think about shows
that run for multiple seasons over a
number of years ultimately it's not that
important in my eyes and probably won't
make that big of a difference in the big
picture they cast the role the first
time and that turned out great why
wouldn't they be able to do a competent
job of replacing him the weird part is
that these trailers really stirred up a
lot of fans and there was no official
announcement that they were bringing a
new actor in i've seen several fan
reports that say the new actor is pat
healy which seemed like a credible
enough idea it definitely looks like him
and he's been engaging with a lot of
better call saul stuff on his social
media but it seems like it would be
pretty easy for the show to pass this
information onto a news outlet and get
it out there if they wanted to temper
expectations around don harvey's return
at this time there's been no official
announcement in the press or on social
media and people are definitely trying
to get them to say something for now i
guess it's nice to see some brand new
footage that adds to all the speculation
they've been stirring up with the promos
they already put out and it does look
like the recast is probably happening as
far as the instagram account that i
mentioned that claimed to have the
insider information about it all about
saul is an account i'm familiar with i
don't know them but i would describe
them as an earnest fan who lives in
albuquerque and posts useful information
because they love the show i don't
really see an angle to making something
like this up but it's possible that
their source doesn't have complete or
correct information it won't be long
until we see it with our own eyes i do
wonder who is eating the cinnabon in
that first clip and i think that's a
good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you think about the
new teasers the unfortunate recasting
and how jeff will play into the end game
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon